[Music]
hello everyone happy Friday I'm Eric
that's Jake how's it going yeah that's
doing alright I guess we had our company
party last night so there are some
people recovering I'm fine though we're
gonna check out
Xenoblade Chronicles 2 it's out and
about for everyone to play now we gave
it or Peter gave it a 7 out of 10 you
can check out his review on gamespot.com
you can also check out the video review
that I think you edited and cut that's
on GameSpot as well as YouTube so I
haven't played at all but Jake and Peter
wanted me to give it a go to see if I
could figure out combat cuz apparently
well we're in the I guess preface where
we're at and how this is gonna go I
guess so this is about 20 minutes in the
game we skipped through some cutscenes
essentially but basically wrecks our
main character here with the
funny-looking pants I've got a job
that's paying a lot of money I think a
hundred thousand goal which is quite a
bit in this game especially early on to
help basically lift something out from
under the clouds he's what they call a
salvager salvager yes thanks brain there
you go
so we're gonna go see what this should I
go is is what I want to do so the reason
we're having aired plays because the
combat is confusing and the game isn't
or tutorial eyes it that well okay so
we're just gonna kind of see what your
thoughts are on it I like I'm helping
you out as we go yeah one thing to say
though is that this is super early so
the combat isn't like too demanding you
won't be needing to do some is it still
confusing at the beginning though or is
it more it gets more confusing I guess
you don't have a blade yet which is like
your yeah my sidekick right yeah and
depending on how far we get there's one
light spoiler at some point okay I can
warn people when we get to that point in
case you want to tune out it's not I
mean it's not within the first hour okay
alright we'll see how I do
do you have other saves I do yeah okay
cool so we could always I want about 20
hours in so we can I can show you what
it looks like a little
later in the game - all right guy go
talk yeah I think we've got a couple
cutscenes we're gonna have to get
through oh yeah
Nia I also turn on the Japanese which
came out today the Japanese language
pack ooh nice
I'm all about that which is yeah it
trust me if you get this game turn it on
there's so many games I mean this game
in particular would it makes a lot of
sense but there's a lot of other games I
wish I could just have Japanese language
pack everything sounds better to me jack
yeah half of the time because I probably
don't understand what they're saying but
then they just have so much like I don't
know charisma and like energy I guess
energy is the better word it's just yeah
you can tell like they just really care
I guess there's a couple lines that get
repeated so many times I do I got yeah
so your objectives
you can't seem right now but there's a
bar up top I see yeah
oh man are they all the way up gene oh
man this guy looks cool
hey you're blocking mess there you go
and then if you guys have any questions
feel free to drop them in the chat I've
played roughly 20 hours so I can try to
answer as much as I can and I'll
obviously I won't spoil anything for
those who are really excited for the
story
whoa yeah all right I wonder what that
would have sounded like in English I
want your alien looking blue you know
right
should I just kind of get through this
yeah I don't think this is super
important I probably should have gone
through this but I figured it would be a
good spot to set up right in front of
the ship I'd like to talk to this guy
all right so it's another guy top I
think hope would turn on subtitles
otherwise are not gonna understand
anything
oh when they talk I can assure you I did
okay
does it have to highlight okay
damn how does he even see alright I'll
start the shift sure
I don't trust that guy man he said he's
gonna have a couple of drinks he's
supposed to be on the watch I wouldn't
trust him
thanks Alex I'll pass those words on to
him he Alex Wald I'm saying that he
thinks Peter is a perfect person to do
the review that's he also played yeah he
also played the first one so sorry
ruining yo yo yo sorry beta I go to AA
meeting on Monday oh I remember this
line I like this guy does not just like
a [ __ ] this kid that's true I did well
we spent 20 hours of them haven't seen
him the drop of liquor
sorry betcha a tear Tosa Iran Domino's
Rhonda darica Gatos tomorrow
Ricardo Castellano
dori mortgage dawson domino touch
psyching artists know cosmo make idiot
throw Cano my Muay Thai all gotten a lot
of slashes in they ignore me the toxin
would start you almost come out better
yeah that's what someone black opine oj
just said that sounds better with
Japanese video with English when we
switch over to mine I'll leave it on the
English okay so we can get a taste of
that how's the story progression the
game do need to grind a lot the story
progresses very slowly for better or
worse like if you like that stuff then
you're gonna like how its placed if you
don't
I haven't had to grind that much
occasionally I will step out of the
whatever I'm doing just to fight a
couple enemies but I've never been like
heavily dated however that I'm still 20
hours and I think Peter said there
weren't really any areas where he felt
he had to grind a whole lot throughout
his 100 hour playthrough her 90 hour
playthrough or something
you know I just remember in the coz like
one of the first things I asked Peter
was like comparing it to the first one
was like so did you hit that revelation
point where like you spent 40 or 50
hours or something like that and then
the game like kind of like unlocked like
a second chapter in a sense because he
got like your mechs and whatnot but uh
it's not like that next and from what
yeah he said the second half is
definitely like way more interesting and
asked more interesting questions which
people who've played Xenoblade will
probably be expecting some of that which
he has but he still said the second half
is much more interesting but it was I
don't think he thought there was like
some huge shift that just changes like
yeah yeah yeah like I I think it was
like X right like halfway connects and
as many people have said yes we are
playing on switches only on the switch
all right don't get the fight yet get in
there
yeah
so those are the key nopon people say
the other thing you should know they're
like these little eggs for jewels that
they're very annoying them but that was
the English voice over there better
thanks
[Music]
how did you bring up that map overlay I
don't know it was just on there yes if
you click the right stick I think right
stick I think it's the right stick you
can get rid of it
dang I look cool compared to these basic
basic guys damn time to swim
no cutscene well another cutscene
what is it
okay ship yeah right you told me I was
going to a ship
almost almost almost there
oh yeah almost day I think we've got
this cutscene you're gonna have another
one maybe one after that is this
cutscene important this one yeah it kind
of is okay then I won't skip me
mm I don't know cuz I'm curious if it
immediately goes into the next one
because I think the next one is
important okay you're afraid that if I
skip it that once you've got it okay oh
sure it's one of those situations where
you like control him and take five steps
and go to the next or
gube says interesting choice you'll
notice when the combat comes up there is
no good yeah yeah yeah if we do make it
through this dungeon there's a really
rad cutscene though so you're saying I
won't make it well I think I don't think
you'll have trouble making it it's more
of just like if we have time you make it
really long I don't remember how long it
is like honestly it could have been an
hour could've been 20 minutes like it
was just like a maze that I walked
through I got to the end fought the boss
or whatever and then
cutscene oh this is over so much this
yeah so right now it's just kind of
giving you ease you pick the characters
you want with you so these three are
with you and this won't be sidelined but
I could kick this guy instead yeah I
would swap just because they're higher
level I would swap with yeah I was gonna
do that also because I think he's a
badass yeah you might actually you may
not be able to beat him sorry Nia you
just pardon your comrades menus
characters change orders one two three
okay I control them one you click the
right stick and get rid of that
do it this trainer list
you can hit it again and it'll just be a
little nap in the corner
I should just be running in there yeah
all right let's go let's go do some
combat oops I'm so used to other games
where I have to actually depress the
left stick to run so yeah I was actually
a guy accidentally brought up the map oh
it's a big bug yeah
battle music hey you're not in my party
so one thing I real say is it is Auto
Attack so you just need to get close
okay I starts swinging to do basic
attack and then are I obviously have
more move right is there is there a
reasoning to have better come on I just
got sword bash it's okay no more chances
[Music]
no problem here what's up playboy she's
still there even I guess she's part of
the story yeah be like an adult I've
been at a or Bayonetta 2 on switch very
good one come on stop talking I want to
fight I want to test my oh what's up
with that guy you'll find out right now
you'll find out
spero beard I know that genome Oh June
chill - so does he sound more annoying
anybody so just go in right yeah
Oh level to God lure down
my too far so far so good chat and no
thing like I said pretty basic right now
[Music]
come at me bro part of the ad DME just
wishes I was actually in effect
weapons yet man oh yes you won't
actually get like I can't jump over
there huh you might have an ability to I
go over and is it oh it's because one of
their blades might be able to let me go
a little closer yeah
now
would it would it would tell me if I
yeah there'd be like no prompting oh
crap Oh down here now coming this way we
won't fight where your buddies are at
and do you regenerate how flights in
between fights okay surprise that guy
has not aggro good that is weird - is
there like a pretty big so weapons with
blades
and how long until you get your like it
looks like a trap level 3
so that flat but why is the behind you
where feel like if you think that is
right there yeah okay I guess they're
going to try to fall down this iteration
no you not get that that's kind of
upsetting like it'd be fine if it was
one of those things where you like if
you walk into it
later Alex yeah yeah we got that Destin
that's we can't wait
why all the drivers in bad looks bad by
Mike I I think they're pretty cool I
think there's some really cool ones like
the common ones you can jump with B but
I think you dropped that hi I think I'm
probably up to do as if to go upstairs
and drop right there that's okay damn
treasure that's not even worth my time
but when we if we have time and we
switch over to my save after we get
through this I can show off some of the
blades that I have someone look pretty
cool like there's no reason for them
they're like behind or fine it's like
doesn't like make things worse or better
[Music]
oh no muscle belt yeah so yeah press
Plus and click on characters muscle
better tool and then hey and then go
over to accessories and you already have
something that I equipped begin throwing
them I got that muscle belt baby 20
strength
is that is that other box worth getting
weird can we just kind of I would just
edge okay oh wait Chris let's go down we
had to kill that guy
[Music]
like okay so what is the actual point of
like aggravating hands versus like just
running up to it I guess when there's
multiple yeah yeah it's just it's just
the basic attacks - so arts and chain
attacks and all that stuff actually
require a button inputs
for a level-two is and take the beating
yeah fights get a long time like just
cuz you're the same level or a couple
levels above them doesn't you're gonna
thrash
[Music]
so I don't know and just like generally
want to be behind like even if they're
like shoot reject house opposite
direction and they're targeting you
you're still gonna get hit gold damn I'm
rich so you want to go to the right up
here Yeah right I just want to get the
treasure but it turns out it was not
worth it
poor wall who knows it's just not worth
it for this stream but we're almost done
with this to help is there a lot of
stuff you end up buying like armor and
gear wise or what's gold or what's
Yancey mainly it's it's gold do you need
to visit shops regularly for many many
reasons for new accessories for fuel
[Music]
it's indicating this way yeah so you
need fuel cells over there
the other ones didn't I need to get the
actual fuel though
well there's a level for let's just
always be on over I guess it'll be
somewhere
I didn't play a whole lot of it so I
don't I can't speak to that I know Peter
reviewed it as well as Xenoblade
Chronicles 1 or Xena breadcrumbs sorry
he reviewed this one and Xenoblade
Chronicles X you can look it yes I heard
that she's very good
level up and I got an art or new art so
also then you know it's alright
so if you uh time your arts like right
after you finish an auto-attack and hit
the button you'll do more damage that's
cool at least there's that yeah we're
just doing about a chapter so rowdy we
might go to a later save just to show
you guys what that looks like we're
early on in the game right now
[Music]
it's got to be like a boss right yeah
let's go king-crab thing
did you 1-shot this I did no problem oh
it's a shark guy why is she here hey he
said interesting I don't think he
actually said that in the subtitle
what's my new art play
[Music]
concentrated oh there's so much more
left him yeah oh we gotta take no
problem easy peasy yeah like this isn't
too hard it's just it's more just
complex look at that muscle shirt yeah
that one cartoon yeah if you're a hired
hand you gotta do what they say sorry so
if you are worried about spoilers
there is a spoiler coming orders yeah I
would leave for a little bit or mute it
and go to a different page come back in
like five minutes maybe it's like not a
huge spoiler but
and like I don't know somewhat
predictable I'd say you know I'll get a
sweet shot
sorry whale that probably won't happen
door after door has through your mind
you are my so yeah last chance I would
if you don't if you don't this spoiled
for you because I would come back in a
way we didn't we kind of already spoiler
for them because I asked you when I was
getting something and he said soon after
this which means isn't that what we're
seeing here anyways if anyone understood
what I was alluding to there yeah what
why don't we have ooh that's sick
give me that I mean getting this is
necessary as well oh so this is higher
this is your blade yeah my new
girlfriend yeah essentially
have you played this game much of port
like on handheld mode a little bit it
looks much better on on a TV okay but
how does it play though fine
yeah plays fine there's just like a
weird it almost looks like someone
cranked up the sharpness way too much on
something and like it's kind of smudgy
not smudgy uh yeah just kind of blurry
but it totally works
I think Peter played most of his
so did you oh wait how do you like
Canada
oh sit dear off cuz he wants it doesn't
he
damn cold-blooded call dick I called the
chat Oh what did he slice it shattered
the sword yeah
that's how he says live he's gonna
absorb the sword
say hi or hopefully does go yeah
ma no kiddos who you'll be
whoa was all a dream mm-hmm that's
probably where you meet my new
girlfriend yep
well I gotta actually get my ass over
there yeah I bet there's treasure behind
this nose game why didn't they just walk
me there was no difference at that point
oh hey man so Japanese yeah
yeah man I know
so like that word I'm saying it I guess
[Music]
face like oh like dark there like what
like I thought yous embarrassed that
like I stabbed us
Nick's on a guy guy DeMuth
Natasha the crane is ready
cuckoo cuckoo cuckoo no sekai toy though
attested to no kioku second Takuma
another that's not a guy I don't know
she needs sake I dunno venomoth Demery
die or asyndeton our own scalp de semana
but as you know he not you humbleness
forever anatomica
tennis a high note or ibotta step two
rival sorta dos mas
weeks
go home I don't cook it all of them
happy yeah sentiments know if you can
change the language we should actually
take a look I'm not sure I changed in
the menu because the Japanese came out
today right the Japanese came out today
so the first 20 CIJ baccarat Toki Hinata
didn't know me Ryan European octet
Nakajima Tara
here you go okay we got home alone
sweetie their necks
so she's giving us half her life force
yes does that mean she's only like
working and operating at half her power
so from what I from what I've played so
far I don't think so but I have a
feeling I'm sure that'll be addressed
yeah at some point it's logically you
know I'm thinking yeah well she's half
of what she normally would be unless
she's just they've made hints like about
like that Oh like yeah that's fine cuz
if she seems like she's like one of the
probably more powerful blades out there
just from like basing on what we've seen
so far maybe it doesn't matter
yeah yeah all right so what should we do
should we keep going from here or should
we load your safe so we're almost there
is sort of an oak action you're gonna
you're gonna do a fight and then eggs I
want to do the might good spots stop I
think then we can load up my section and
I cannot man I really hope I get the
sword like I hope it just materializes
again yeah nailed it so your weapons
change based on which blade you have
equipped and I think there's like 14 or
18 different Wow okay yeah this is a
sword obviously I have gauntlets that we
can check out some other characters of
different things yeah it's got the I
don't even know what those are called
the circular blade pendants oh yeah I
know you're talking about I don't know
what they're called I know what you're
talking about I can visualize it I just
can't I don't know the proper name saver
village or family or something
oh come on tiger
yeah it's so hot
good morning
[Music]
what a grand entrance I'm not a scrub
anymore fire
[Music]
like he knows how to fight bringing us
back what could she do
[Music]
chakram thank you yeah damn it that's it
really oh she's stuck
[Music]
the soy
ooh I got sonic scream too
but what is this combination attack
[Music]
burning 40 yeah no that's how they would
say it though in an anime panning gisado
ojk
I'm special ooh damn all right so after
that sweet cutscene now you actually
yeah okay do I actually have to control
her - or she kinda okay so basically she
like fuels the power of yours now you
have the same moves since we're using
okay for it just as like there's more
damage elemental yes
you know playoffs Hachi formation so I
don't have to worry about his blade
either that name no I mean 'ti what is
the bond of life
[Music]
what Bond play is it the thing under my
HP you know that's your level I drop
this shows bolding
we synchronize our ability oh I just
need to be right next to her
[Music]
really I have to keep that in mind I
have to be next to okay come over here
[Music]
everything I'm doing is doing like yeah
but I'm doing that I'm on fire I got
that heat can yeah so every time you so
I did that some more okay also we use a
special building to execute a button
challenge the special is the far-right
one another time I want to know right
now so you need others blades perfect
can't even need that help
oh dude I should be going way too early
too early premature swing
let's go have to power it up or do I
actually just do it today now oh now we
get to talk about it great Oh what is
all that on the top right
okay alright after yourself a minutes
you'll see a gauge at the top of screen
okay
possible routes okay
[Music]
basic AC you see this heat meter yeah
so basically ends up here you must fall
late on of these passed by those are
specials of that type once complete orb
and when you get a chain attack a
special attack you can burst that or but
it doesn't ton of damage that's a lot of
things to uh yeah take in and one thing
P mentions reviews there's no way to go
back what these are and like right there
like while that stuff course
Bob Jones and snow if you're a Xenoblade
man this is your first single yes my
first one
I mean I've played a bunch of like JRPGs
and stuff like growing up so we decided
to let him play these for the first part
because we want to see how far it isn't
and it did kind of told me some of that
stuff albeit a little later like I
didn't know about the like you know
perfect timing of getting a you know an
arch after an attack to do more damage
so until like fair right I also started
like 20 minutes into it when it did say
that oh man he's got worldly verses do
that
Oh is he dealing with the with Nia
[Music]
go shopping in my amends
really old
just seems like a time traveler then by
trying it like is right the present look
at that
I can unfold all the stories just from
the first chapter
oh it's time for or they gonna help us
yeah
[Music]
that's a good question happy accident is
like give a explain why they the I
blades need drivers think they do but I
don't remember why exactly I'd like to
think they can't exist without the
driver but or maybe the bond makes them
stronger
you know what it is so higher is a
little different which they explain to
explain a little later but if they don't
have a driver than they're kind of stuck
in this crystal so basically the driver
is how they awakened yeah so they're
kind of where I am they kind of touch on
it but basically if a driver dies then
he late goes back into that org and it
like it's basically by it so it needs a
recharge something and papyrus assailant
works different
why did he call the dragon his grandpa
or was his grandpa on the dragon oh he
called the drag on his oh really and
apparently the grandpa knows these guys
and they know him so I was dragging
these I don't think it's actually
because anim yeah
[Music]
it's fairy tale if you guys have ever
watched the anime fairy tale we're not -
the main character gets raised - by a
dragon and so in this case Rex is
clearly have been written that I'm just
but it probably has some
[Music]
No
series title see who you shot him
ughn nice
I'll have to turn that off
the pretty boy evil guys easy to read
[Music]
do you guys have any chapters or in the
game ten chapters some of them were
really long I think
this wraps up chapter one which is like
probably by far the shortest yeah or no
we're starting chapter one now no what
do you want you now yeah like it's 30
minute what's this do you want me to
save it doesn't matter I had to do one
different profile it's fine one save
okay but yeah we can switch over to mine
okay I have to go back to the switch
menu though okay I can go camera here
all right we're just gonna quickly
switch to Jake's Tony our save so he's
discussed which user accounts on the
switch but yeah that was kind of like
the the early intro to the game we
skipped maybe 20 minutes in the
beginning there together quest 12
minutes of cutscenes and tutorials yeah
very solid for you know that opening
area especially if you've played the
Xenoblade games before and you enjoyed
them you know all right
oh wow your screen looks different yeah
so the further along you get it it's
kind of like a final fantasy did that to
you I think 15 yeah
can I go back or do you or I'll go back
I mean it's black that's loading so
we'll give it a second macario's do you
guys recommend yes yes I'm actually this
is should be English alright
hey get fast travel somewhere like a
fast travel
let me check see if I can change the
sound
yeah so it's English alternate battle
narration also just so you guys if you
guys could see there there is like a
time day/night cycle and I heard that
influences the game in different ways
like enemies and stuff like that it does
I don't understand influences okay
like tides yeah I don't know wow that's
his voice yeah oh man I'm probably going
to only be able to bear this for five
minutes it's my guess it's bad because
we went the opposite right we went from
what I perceive as good to now like just
like probably what I don't want to hear
so how important is the gem collecting
it's just like I you know they just like
to craft things too like upgrade you
just need that stuff like I don't know I
haven't particularly liked didn't like
oh I need this item really bad right now
I just kind of get him anyway uh Eureka
from the little bit that Jake said
earlier he said handheld was fine but
it's better docked he said I think you
said it was like sharper like too sharp
almost yeah not like sharp is in like
not sharp is in like high resolution
just like there was almost like a
sharpness filter that had been turned up
like play around I'm sure you don't like
a sharpness dial on like Photoshop or
something it's a little bigger crank
this crank up have you been able to
mount and ride anything or have you just
mainly been running I've leaned these in
runnings if I change I think too low if
I change too
Nia then you can okay I forget how do
someone said Nia's not playable but I'm
guessing that's false
yeah okay so you can't can you ride
between years okay but this disputes the
same though that's cool though oh yeah
my knees do you have a favorite
character so far that you like playing
more than the others or they come to be
honest I actually haven't switched from
Rex is the first time I'm Rex okay I
just stuck with him it was like yeah
it's it's games enough as is and a
suspect
Oh level 73 did you see that we're not
we're not messing with him are you sure
I can will die so quick there's a lot of
fast travel happy act accidents so I'm
sure you don't have to walk all up all
those stairs if you didn't want some I
can also show some off show off some of
the other blades - okay so you can
switch yeah all right so this is I
forgot her name already it's been an in
no no no so CLA Cora Cora none of my
blades different I know your weapon here
different I have fish weapons and that
affects your heart so the only equipment
you put on then is it mainly armor them
not actual okay and then you would be
upgrading your blade then yes you oh you
can switch blades on the fly I'm kind of
sis there's a core bound now
but so someone did a break then I use my
anti-shock awful one of the old Final
Fantasy online games kinda had this
thing work my friend would have a piece
of paper out because he would you know
he'd be do killing stuff with like other
classes and it's like it would be kind
of like that where's like you're trying
to link skill combinations together to
get more damage enemies that seems
pretty complex though like I know yeah
so do they teach you that stuff or is it
stuff you learn okay so they do the
issue is that like the tutorials aren't
that good and you can't like there's no
way to go back and look at them and
because we live in a day where
instruction manuals don't come with
games anymore like yeah it just you look
we need them game facts I know how many
characters are there we know party well
we can only have three characters in our
party oh time your party how many have
you found
I guess playable for so far are okay and
you're know who they've been like
hinting at hinting at who's been like
I've had interactions with occasionally
huh
and then blades I can actually pull up
the screen of raids so this is the late
album so this is oh wow so there's so
these are all the rare ones these are
only rare ones I have unique designs oh
we actually have poppy poppy is an
artificial play a little bit differently
I'm not gonna get into a that's fine but
so Cora and you get him randomly through
crystals except for pirate and like ones
that are based on the team she makes me
feel uncomfortable okay she's like a
fish lady but then here are whoa my
blades so like these guys are all calm
and they look they have the same
aesthetic can you just sell those I
can't sell them listen okay but you want
to keep them later because there's a
synchronous like you know those games
were you like
like I having Assassin's Creed did it or
it's like you send off people in they
complete a mission 20 minutes oh god
yeah okay so it's like good hold on to
them and then I can switch blades but
yeah what is in your helmet so or is a
spoiler it's kind of a spoiler we were
about to get to it okay after you get
attacked like that yeah I won't say it
but yeah I have a feeling based off of
what you just said well I'm not gonna
say anything so somebody's saying that
there's six-party members maybe until it
looks like there's room for six yeah
that's what someone said they named all
six of our no.5 it looks like I don't
know this guy I don't know Parvez eNOS
said six and he lists a bunch of people
so I don't know if I want to look at
that one thing that Peter did say is
that like some people come and go like
you know okay
typical JRPG yeah you just get them for
like certain like chapters or whatever
because it's like person of interest or
whatever all right have you noticed much
variance in terms of like the weapons or
is it just more about the arts that
you're doing at that point
I guess because that's
okay new fire voice is awful gotcha
geez is like I forgot who said it
earlier but Pam there are there is a lot
of stuff going on on this case that is
why it's not the middle-left guys this
is this is the only place we could have
put it and it's still blocking something
like yeah if there's like actual AI or
enemy there this is a tough River
abundant really oh because this thing's
like three levels higher than you
this one's not one of them is that 2000
there's okay there was three guys I'm
kind of fine so now you're doing wind
right where you want to or across okay
so wind again is orange there earth
but another guy just came
oh he's in the air that's cool arts plus
I hate his voice
[Music]
so you still have the same moves that I
have with this weapon
Oh with the sword because they're just
weapons type of weapon where you give
you lightning genuine into water
yep you died well good work
so you even find a tougher enemy so I
can do it so it's all for looks man
those bunnies are way did ya go the boat
everything be okay
do you get more if it's closer to them
to the B button or does I know it's just
within that time frame
look how that guy's like hey I don't not
even helping his buddy
so see what I do there know what I do
there is an easy level to since I
already hit level one so it didn't chain
it then it didn't change the right I
messed up you've got another one oh and
I forgot to mention in order special now
is or are you gonna do a little too okay
you got a little too now okay
oh so just damn it kill them yeah I see
what you're going for there though
you're a second of the third chain
depending on where you go right yeah so
but then how do with him okay so does
your party can your party also do it
though yes they can right I would have
had I have to rely on to rely on rock
because what he has got water because
she gets steamed well she's got to play
okay
do they try to match what you need or do
you like yeah so they okay they should
typically match and I think they don't
even like normally like if I'm doing a
movie a level above that so Kazik it
does Auto Attack the couple of things
that are you're not necessarily seeing
is one of the things is after certain
just normal attacks you wanna you know
do an art or you're special to do more
damage and then now in the top right
corner you see that we've triggered the
bolt or the lightning so he switched to
pyro which gives you fire which means he
the next super he does will kind of
trigger the next chain and then he'll
need I think we said name is roxrite or
uni dropped from her that's wind back
to finish the third the third thing so
now he's gonna do fire - all right so
now he can either go down the seal blow
down or steel shackle wait he use his
movement is right there now this thing
to finish plate combo third stage ooh
that's a lot of damage okay so now she's
gonna do a Ross made right oh what's
that
this is a chain attack that with that
top left so he's got that so basically
if I burst that it'll do a ton of damage
and I'll get to continue this after I
did some damage to it there
almost for the next hit I like how she's
dancing at all but it's it's him first
he just has rock which is when
unfortunately oh it did work cool so now
did a ton of damage oh so it did a ton
of damage I bursted that I get to
continue okay chain normally it would
stop after all three people got it but
it was the right but since I bursted
that I get to go again so we'll do go
for it now right it's just like these
three extra attacks because you bursted
right yeah overkill start it yeah there
we go so you can like keep stacking
those orbs essentially so like he was
saying one of the later bosses you
basically want to like get as many orbs
on the enemy as possible and then when
you get to the end of him because he's
got a one-hit kill you just want to keep
chaining yeah to get as much yeah
possible I'm surprised we actually got
that because it took Peter and I for a
long time too well now that you know how
to do it right like it's like whoa like
you said you were almost afraid that you
weren't getting at the burst because of
the combination there but yeah so
there's definitely layers to combat
that's for sure there is so if we want I
can fight a story boss sure how spoiler
is that I can skip the cutscene I'm just
fighting so I fought it before and lost
I'm gonna grind more but really I think
you're gonna win I think so I hope it
should not require we're not even on a
network connection right now so you
shouldn't need it to play handheld I
mean it's all single-player right yeah
yeah all right going to try to fight a
boss part of me says that the game will
explain everything you need to know it
will but the issue is is that it hits
you with so much so soon and a lot of it
like isn't that relevant
like for instance it was explaining what
we just did to you yeah when you only
have one element so it's like what how
are you gonna change those yeah well I
could have went fire fire and then I
don't know
yeah I'd have to go fire fire fire and
like you once
like once that stuff passes by you don't
get to look at it again I I hope they'll
patch that and I have a feeling they
will they will you can buy tips from
informants but I see some people are
talking about the combat and how like
it's a little daunting I guess and it
would be nice to have like a Jake tell
you what to what to do or like explain I
guess what's going on there's a chest to
your left
shiny I think you have patience I think
that these like the systems are there
and you can learn them
it does seem but there are quite a bit
but oh no I feel like yeah I mean with
time you once you figure it out you
figured it out 80 hour maybe longer game
so you're gonna have time to figure
these things out but it like it can be
daunting so I got a core crystal and
what that does is blades are inside of
them so I'm gonna open it just a common
one so I probably won't get anything
good and normal so all of the rare ones
I've gotten have been from a common one
though the rare ones I'll get it's just
like completely random together we don't
need that in the chat right now yeah so
this is just a common one feels bad he's
got a gun does that mean you have a gun
then yeah well actually no I can't I
would say you're about to quite up
because so when you reach a certain
point you can have three blades equipped
oh really but I'm not at that point and
I'd rather have Cora and NIM hooked and
I can't add one for a rock for some
reason I don't know why I think he's one
of those characters that will leave
eventually alright so we're gonna try a
story boss we're gonna skip through the
cutscene so you guys not to worry about
spoilers it'll just give you a like a
taste of something of a bigger scale
yeah
and it'll be a good way to kind of end
the stream hopefully kill him
but as you said you might have to grind
a little bit more but whatever we're
doing it
oh oh it's those guys again yeah except
that guys by the bounty hunter he said
he's gonna send out for you
but I'm guessing this isn't the boss oh
this is the walk okay who he's dueling
blades we need that guy I want
Actos is there a weapon blade do a
wheeled man
[Music]
all right
your AoE attacks kick both of them you
can do it Rex just kidding that's
something they're doing to you down
everyone's getting psyched I would
implore you if you're gonna buy this
game and play it please download the
Japanese voice pack and which is free
and out today because it sounds a lot
better in Japanese than it does in
English oh you need something life he is
dead
keep it together and your whole party's
really looks right now Oh van ham
to see I can't read because I don't have
enough bar so this meter also it's a
little bit tougher
I haven't grinded like it all yeah once
I got here I'm like I know I should
grind so it seems like yeah grind out
one or two yeah that's what I was gonna
say I think that like the 25 26 and it
seems like at least when I was playing
even in the early stages it feels like
it became kind of wanted to be at the
same level or like one or two levels
higher because even when you were
fighting those 2223 like little rabbits
they weren't dying like that fast so
that makes sense
well combat takes a while just to begin
with but also there's enhancing arts so
like I need a sea shoes all level one
right now for this weapon so I'm gonna
level up all these arts that might be
part of the reason why okay and how do
you get WP you just use that blade okay
all right so that's and so since that
was that was WP for this weapon I can go
back to this weapon and it's different
right yeah yeah okay which I don't know
why this is still left one and then on
top of that so she's gotten an affinity
chart and I actually have enough points
to do that maybe I should upgrade
increase HP I will do this
I'll look at this later yeah interesting
yeah but then I have so I have that for
all the characters right but then I go
to blades wow they have their own too
much more yep even all the common ones
have this weapon modification extra sure
probably yeah oh there's different
swords huh actually maybe I should give
her the weapon modification no that does
nothing for her okay give it to pirate
then increase agility by 50% okay so
that's stuff you just find right
yeah yeah so that's like what when you
like pull things out of the ground
sometimes you'll get this
there's ox cores to that you equipped
all your blades they're like accessories
but four blades and a lot of them you
can't use because it's unrefined you
have to go to that's where the like
stuff I pull out of the ground comes
into play you need that in order to
upgrade it essentially or to activate to
act so you can use it to refine it
exactly okay yeah yeah it's definitely a
deep game so thank you for showing that
to us Jake so yeah it's out today if you
guys are curious I want to play it for
yourselves it's on the Nintendo switch
of course as mentioned you can download
the Japanese voice pack we recommend it
or I do at least yeah we'll see you guys
next week we'll be streaming next week
as well I know destiny to DLC is coming
out there might be a few other things
and of course I think December 11th is
when we start our best of 2017 for
GameSpot where we'll be kind of counting
down our top 10 game of the year or
games of the year top 10 games of the
year or best of the year rather so we'll
start from 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 and then on
the last day we will reveal 3 2 1 so
we'll be live-streaming
each one of those days
different you know editors and video
producers here will be on those streams
to kind of talk about why they like
those games why those games are
important for the year and eventually
after that we'll just play some and hang
out with you guys in chat so you guys
should come hang out with us I think
you're on a couple of those right Jake I
am I won't say which ones yeah obviously
way but yes I'm on a few so until next
week and then the week after that for
best of thank you guys all and have a
good weekend thanks so much for playing
today Jake thank you later
[Music]
[Music]